Laurence pharin parce que là on parle de
ces pays là mais
à l'ouest chez nous
est-ce que est-ce que la situation est
rose pour autant alors qu'est-ce que
vous appelez bonjour à tous se passe
bien à l'ouest chez nous par exemple en
France en France on a une structuration
des médias qui est équilibrée avec une
télé publique qui a son financement on a
aussi des vrais organes de régulation
parce que je sais pas si on parlera du
règlement pour la liberté des médias
européens mais ça c'est un gros enjeu
d'avoir un organe de régulation fiable
ensuite il y a une question sur lequel
sera au copain le futur texte sera
opérant le futur texte européen c'est le
phénomène de concentration et là oui il
y a des questions qui se posent au sont
même des frontières hexagonales
je peux en parler librement parce que
j'étais à l'initiative avec mon collègue
David gourmand d'une initiative sur la
future fusion Lagardère Vivendi qui oui
pose problème notamment au prisme de ce
futur texte européen parce que
et bien il y a des questions qui se
posent sur l'indépendance sur la
concentration
aux mains de quelques-uns et donc d'une
forme d'oligarchie c'est le cas en
France sur beaucoup de titres puisqu'il
y a je crois 10 actionnaires principaux
pour
801% des abdos il y a des questions en
effet de concentration sur des titres
comme par image gala c'est que la
Commission européenne en train de de
réfléchir beaucoup sur ce point il y a
quand même des des suspicions sur
l'intervention dans la rédaction ça a
été le cas pour Paris Match sur des une
sur des changements à la fin à la tête
de la rédaction donc c'est pour ça qu'on
a réagi et qu'on a fait une lettre à la
Commission européenne en demandant de
voir ce qui se passait et je vois qu'on
a été entendu parce que Margaret
verchtager mène une enquête approfondie
sur ce sujet
de ce texte de cette loi alors
en plus il y a des bas est-ce que ce
sera un règlement en gros est-ce que ça
s'impose directement au 27 ou est-ce que
c'est une directive et à ce moment-là
chacun des 27 peut l'adapter dans son
droit alors d'une manière globale
j'attends de ce règlement que l'Union
européenne puisse agir de manière
structurelle sur la démocratie et l'État
droit on voit bien qu'on a été jusqu'à
l'or très bloqué par la question de
sanction vers les États qui dérogaient à
ces principes article 7 bloqué par le
principe de l'unanimité donc on n'a
jamais pu avancer avec la Hongrie et la
Pologne on a fait un pas très récemment
avec la conditionnalité des fonds
européens qui permettent pas d'argent
européen c'est pas de respect des
valeurs européens qui ont véritable
utilité on voit que la Pologne parce que
c'est fondre l'ensemble ok avancent sur
les régimes des sanctions vers les juges
donc on voit que ça aussi dans le
domaine de l'Ascension on a avancé
maintenant avec ce texte on fait une
étape de plus sur le pas fait de rendre
structurel nos exigences par rapport au
respect de la démocratie et de l'état
droit donc ça c'est tout à fait majeur
donc ce texte et bien
d'abord en effet il y a un débat est-ce
que c'est un règlement indirectif c'est
un règlement parce que il doit
s'appliquer en l'état dans les six mois
sa promulgation alors une directive doit
être transposée et donc on va rentrer
dans des débats nationaux qui risquent
de le bloquer bon donc premier point
après comme vous le dites ce texte il
énonce des principes très basiques oui
protection des journalistes
protection de la liberté et de
l'indépendance des médias lutte contre
la concentration et ça c'est le point
clé parce qu'on l'a vu dans les débats
qu'on a eu les médias qui peuvent être
rachetés les médias privés qui peuvent
être rachetés par le public les
concentrations dans par des oligarques
des proches du pouvoir tous ces points
sont importants donc
j'attends qu'il s'applique dans une dans
un règlement et qu'après les étapes
puissent mettre en place des éléments de
contrôle il y a un truc fou quand même
c'est que il y avait pas d'organismes de
régulation quand on parle du kaboloré en
France le cabot Lauret en France on a à
la recommande on a des principes de
régulation française mais dans d'autres
États ça n'existe pas ça veut dire que
le futur s'appelle le Comité européen
des services de médias devra remonter à
la Commission dans chaque pays ce qui se
passe dans son propre pays exemple en
Grèce en Pologne en Hongrie quand il y a
des concentrations qui sont qui peuvent
et voyez des soupçons il faudra remonter
ces points à la commission donc ce sera
un levier important pour agir et pour
apporter des par la loi sachant que bon
et la loi suffit pas toujours et la
pression internationale peut jouer un
rôle des coûts changer l'Europe a
beaucoup changé à cause de la guerre en
Ukraine un tabou tombe on est en train
de devenir une puissance militaire
dans ces dramatiques impérieuses
actualités comme on a avancé sur le
covid en avance enfin sur l'Europe de la
défense et en effet c'est une révolution
on a fait un pas de plus et on a fait un
pas aussi j'ai noté que la Hongrie qui
était opposée jusqu'à présent à aller
plus loin c'est abstenu sur ce sur cette
décision donc ça veut dire qu'en effet
on est en train de construire l'Europe
de la défense et on est en train de
construire notre souveraineté parce que
ce qu'a fait Thierry Breton en allant
faire le tour des de nos industries
européennes ça veut dire souveraineté de
notre armement et c'est un gros débat
qu'on a avec tous les fonds qu'on veut
développer pour pour rebâtir notre
industrie de la défense donc oui une
réelle avancée avec cette décision
intervenue cette semaine